all right we have decided that we would
be better off running past the nemesis
and just saving up all this animal and
health rather than get the assault rifle
I think it's a good idea I had a cookie
and a beer and I still feel like an
absolute [ __ ] I'm like it's the
lowest point mm-hmm that I've ever been
in probably in my video game career I
hate this game
and I'm really [ __ ] mad and I after we
finished that episode I tried three more
times just because I was upset and I
still didn't do it so I'm at the point
where I realize I'm not good at this
game I think for morale and supplies I'm
just gonna cry my way through this I've
never felt so low I'm not out of it yet
tough game
you'd think a cookie and a beer would
make me feel better about it know what
up north the bell jar the bell door the
bell jar
[ __ ] that guy so much I can't believe 12
grenades isn't enough it's just I don't
know what to say
I like I'm out I'm out my heart can't do
it run for the rest of my freakin life
no spiders they just not spawn I don't
know he's gone now at this point like
what do I care
come at me like I give a [ __ ] about some
freaking spiders I just have my [ __ ]
handed to me for like last 50 minutes I
was like this once when I played
blood-borne I got so god damn mad
imagine if blood-borne had like a
persistent threat at a yeah at a boss it
was um I bet you you're like it's not
even a hard boss um it was like the icy
dog or something and I just it's early
on and I just [ __ ] it took me like
three hours how about Dark Souls 3
yeah yeah I am I don't know the shaggy
dog is uh there was a dog - anything
with the dog for him does another save
so wait okay but I'll get a key no yeah
you're a it was in Dark Souls 3 I'm like
our key I think I'm mentally done I
don't know if I should go you should go
on I got stuck in blood-borne to
remember what his name was but he sucked
this this is how I feel I feel like I
feel like in a in a Dark Souls or
blood-borne game and I just feel
absolutely defeated like I just feel so
broken inside so is that this door you
think the park yeah I should check for
items shouldn't I yeah what's broken I'm
talking about the TV it'd be nice if
there was like
something special here
anything to boost morale would be a huge
bonus thank you thank you so much I
really needed this should keep these
mines do you think I need these mines I
haven't been very helpful tell you Irena
I've learned heaps to like I promise you
I will never make another shotgun shell
for the rest of this game
I am so focused on making magnums mm-hmm
freeze rounds are better than magnums
but apparently oh I really thought I
dodged that
name me a time we felt as low as I feel
right now every day of my life
no I feel like I shouldn't have a
shotgun for those that's right man that
was a slow turnaround well it worked
and you're dead it's the first thing
I've killed no more an hour a sad day
for my existence
mm-hmm I never oh come on I shot you I
hurt like running out of hills here my
heart hurts from being sad
I'm just looking for I don't know I
doubt anything cool would be in here I'm
a little desperate I'm like pretty low
on health you know
the this is a sad day it's a sad day in
married town yeah need a gear it didn't
work the Nemesis is going to jump over
it
and I write cool the shape of the
fountain changes based on the
combination of the gears oh it's one of
those puzzles okay so what kind of
puzzle do kind of shape do we want is
the question and why Oh bless your heart
why are they always blue though I think
those drained Deimos those liquor things
can poison you if I'm not mistaken right
yeah you said that before I just like
have not gotten poisoned from them it's
probably the only good luck I've had in
this godforsaken okay all right so what
am i doing we're trying to open I'm
trying to get here I assume yes so you
don't need a gear you just I don't need
a gear but I need to be able to make the
right shape let's go down there Jeff
something can you go down I can't yes I
can
okay yeah uh black up top white on the
bottom as it should be - black up top
weight on the bottom get up there dumb
them oh wait wait wait sorry
so black top - right that's right
no wait wait wait wait go back go back
go back go back right now okay mmm yeah
now do the bottom right black one oh you
don't have a certain amount of turns ah
that makes sense
oh my heart oh and it resets got it okay
yeah now do a white one black top right
white top left black yeah
I can't why
damn those bumbles look dad this is like
probably what it feels like when you're
like playing a game but you just broke
up with your persecutor of of your life
you're just like pain won't go away yeah
I don't even love I have let's go on
drugs oh man that's a no you're going
against the currents that blood dude
what are you gonna fight the gravedigger
it doesn't look good though
okay so I just need to get in there
oh you how to play goes ok yeah [ __ ]
about you oh crap
follow me morons in your depression
you've gained patience
it's just sadness it manifests in my
sadness I no longer feel like there's a
reason to live
so I kind of take more risks now herbs
oh that looked awful like bad no sorry I
coughed in the mic I just liked I was so
surprised that that happened
I hate that guy well let's utilize all
these stupid shotgun shells I made some
dumb and I didn't realize how important
they were that grave just says Patrick
it's all that well probably his nickname
was this Foreman patty be okay I wonder
if this is like a maze thing doesn't
matter should I just keep going like I
haven't been over there yeah check it
out red herbs that's worth it come here
you're pressing me have you ever seen me
deal with death depression before where
absolute sadness I'm gonna be a sad show
folks I've got it any whiskey or
something
raccoon Park Cemetery so what do I do
that's it I didn't get anything am I
supposed to play is the boy again do I
need a key should I be checking these
graves
do you have the did you put the park key
away uh threw it away in the box no it
said it was done you she's a lock back
on that door you try normally when you
try to open it it just says use lockpick
though you know what I mean
I need a pet sematary key park Oh
me little stuck just a little stuck
through that it said the park he was
done wonder if there's anything else
gonna go they drop down with me
under what I missed I must have missed
see somewhere I don't remember that
happening that you know here we are like
is there something around here check
your math again
I don't know what I could have missed
what's over this way did you go here yet
I don't even know I guess not
try that side okay this place is a lot
bigger than I thought I know where you
going that's the wrong door oh I thought
you meant over here yeah you just
mumbling now it's gonna be all right
like I didn't even know there was this
other side so obviously like wasn't
paying attention
yeah I didn't even see this I no idea
was existed I'm not I'm not it like that
Oh probably Joo Kim I mean just kill
them
certainly not worth my health is a no
way back or now cheer up up with you
here's something heads up
oh no doggy's no oh I hate dogs I still
hear it another one somewhere
yeah I burned through their shotgun
shells pretty fast
even that goddamned cemetery Keith sweet
check that trash I will I love trash
yeah observe and record combat data of
the UBC s stroy evidence including the
facility in the medical treatment data
oh that's that guy he must have planted
the bomb check the guinea pigs ability
to accomplish the mission once the
mission is complete evacuate the area
remember that you must not help anyone
who is not a supervisor nor bring
anything back that might be traced where
it belongs interesting really she
appears to be shot to death this looks
like a dangerous area
and you look like you've been shot to
death shotgun rounds nice even better I
will take those that's [ __ ] liquid
gold is this the key that I have or no
coming back through here though okay yep
it's back where I was on the other side
all right so I needed to come through
here all right well that's good no a
waste sweet a small victory but a
victory nonetheless I needed anything I
would have taken dead dogs
[Music]
you can go behind if you want okay well
not anymore
I feel like you got to be more clear
behind what else would that mean I don't
know I didn't okay that's true what
happened I'll leave that one one broken
if the Nemesis comes in fighting me in
here I think I'll just lay down and well
I'll pick a controller up no giving up
it's not the Knievel spirit I know
there's no way this is the hardest
Knievel yes there is
how was this not the hardest you think
this is the hardest can eat like you're
on out yeah
100% played four five six having you
[ __ ] you like I have time for this [ __ ]
yeah I play them they're easy yeah
that's true I'll be playing five and six
with you that's exciting
excited mix it up a little bit you know
okay we're going places Mike you and me
please G powder in here god yes
and a spear of some sort okay did I say
to start making some freeze rounds I can
combine them now and save the inventory
space sure I was gonna do it anyway with
where my heart is that all I want to do
is make 4000 freeze rounds and kick that
guy's ass all right so I want to combine
these don't combine these like you can
yeah and then mix it
do you have other aids in your inventory
yes I have a lot of it
no don't why'd you do that you should
not have done that I should not have
done no that just waste that's like 20
freeze round geez missed out on by doing
that no those are freeze rounds I'm
pretty positive it's not no those are
free drones ciencias free drones oh I
see we're okay sorry I made them for an
hour I know them okay cool
sweet I plan to do a Windows nevermind
no that's the heated rooms I wish it was
I kind of want to save cuz I'm just so
afraid of dying at this point just from
being so bad
Mo's later with you I do not probably
like that what it looks like okay we're
safe room safe room when you open oh
it's right behind you sweet I'd say go
get you a lighter all right you know
it's safe okay happy with that do you
think there's something bad coming up
that I should be careful for probably
yeah
oh good thank you I'll take it you could
make some freeze rounds now for what -
yeah I will cuz I was going to anyway I
was gonna make can you make tripsy or
know that woods make Magnum should I
make Magnum no I think freeze rounds are
better alright we talked about this
apparently magnums won't hurt though
magnums won't what won't hurt to have
well they require an extra C so there's
no reason to do it
[Music]
god I wish I had this just a second ago
when life have been sweet cool so let's
save and keep keep on truckin wait how
do you not have ten more freeze groans
what happened the other ones again I
didn't make them cuz I died every time I
made those three rounds I died so I can
make more now if you think that's the
best thing to do I haven't I haven't
survived long enough to make any of
these
all right there's 20 freeze rounds it's
pretty good all right so there's 20
freeze rounds and then I need a lighter
and then I need to safe we can get going
I'm okay nope
that's a closer
okay I think I need anything else you
think I'm good
I got sixteen shotgun give me the
lockpick I honestly don't know I
wouldn't bring take out some of those
arms wait you saved yeah you did yes
it's done okay you got the lighter too
right yep no I'm not sorry that mic snap
funny that blew up the house and
brennick dust this is nice wow that was
a really dry wood like really dry like
that was starving
ok ok interesting take the map again ok
maybe I should use this tube out I'm
back
interesting use those hamstrings
well I'm strong and independent and
slightly depressed get out of my way
she just slithered in there wait sorry I
got excited you're not to read out lives
anything important all right no that's
not reading music hey nothing important
just talking about how they become dumb
okay
POWs damn I have heard that there's a
giant alligator but I've only ever
counted giant creature moving under the
ground
no no he's talking about two things the
giant alligator I think you killed him
too
I've only ever encountered but I've only
encountered a giant creature moving
underground I don't want to imagine what
creatures spawn
oh man you're gonna fight the
gravedigger soon oh [ __ ] you're about to
hit the gravedigger know what that is
that will giant worm thing I I already
killed that I didn't you just escaped it
up the ladders oh that's the other to go
all the way there's that again
kill Earl on that's it
there's nothing here but some docs
where's my grenade launchers rounds on
there so let's say give me something
like holy crap
okay I guess that's it you just combine
regular grenade rounds with gunpowder
see it makes freeze rounds Oh does it
it's me the gravedigger okay how the
[ __ ] did he get in and out of this room
he squeezed through that little hole did
you check his body I did okay
I'm quite impressed you've managed to
stay alive up until now
[Music]
and you seem to be doing a pretty good
job of looking out for yourself how
about helping out I have no intention of
helping you because we're nothing but
pawns and all this you dick in a manner
of speaking you are our employers wanted
the detailed analysis of the zombie
beings which were created through
infection by the t-virus you're saying
that they deliberately sent in a
military unit to be butchered by their
creations not exactly
although the conditions encountered on
this operation were extreme it was an
unexpected outcome that the team would
be wiped out we were only required to
collect live data from the subjects
another mutant wait do you think I
should get a lot of [ __ ] for this fight
my guess is I'm going to fight something
what you wanna save now
yeah whatever I could get oh I don't
have any more bees so I can I can make
flame realms alright so what do you mean
a brain should I bring regular yeah I
wouldn't use rounds okay here's my
grenade launcher and here's some regular
rounds and like I said I could make them
flame rounds I have a lot of egg one two
three four five five maybe you could
make flame rounds do you want but
all right do I have everything I need
[Music]
your health might be nice
I hate that grave thing so much oh no am
I gonna fall I'm gonna fall what's going
on already happened before
oh it's bigger it's a huge like teeth
penis
[Music]
run
don't know I feel like I should get this
out
yes yes of course
get ready shoot I'll run that [ __ ]
caution should I heal
it's a tough one
where is it no [ __ ] idiot
well he'll it sucks like huh I know I
can't prove what happens when you're out
of shot
oh I got two left
make don't don't shoot if you can't see
it because it's been going down oh right
what dammit dammit sorry
I remember what you said
oh I really thought I was safe
[Music]
look that thing and it's stupid but I
was that what then mean it doesn't well
these over right damn it
damnit do something happen don't look at
me like that oh I'm getting electrocuted
wait maybe that hurts oh is this a fight
in the world no is that what you're
saying I've run a long time
oh that's horseshit I'll shoot it now
I'm no stranger to death anymore just
sucks because we have to listen to that
stupid-ass cutscene again also I felt
like I was really close to killing it
yeah me too
kind of breaks me down
[Music]
don't give a [ __ ]
apparently you can just evade him for a
while and the light post happens not
because you're hurting it oh but I
should be killing it right then you have
to hit the light post when he's in the
water I don't know what you mean shoot
the life oh shoot the light post when
he's in the water
yeah electrocute him I feel like there
wasn't a lot of I don't feel like it
educated me about that you got
electrocuted when you were standing in
the water how much better can be
educated so I'm supposed to shoot the
light pole that's what that's why they
fell into the water because you turn
around in it that's why it magnetized
your aim to the light pole you missed
so get skip this can you skip it with
the niccola this conversation no can't
do anything just like the ultimate
insult to injury is like how much we
come on how much we like accomplished
before that death even though we didn't
like do that much but like I had to come
in here and to get all the stuff I had
to like I combined a bunch of [ __ ] I
made freeze rounds I guess I could just
not make the freeze rounds just drop
them off again yes bring the Magnum with
you instead of using flame rounds maybe
why no just don't you could make freeze
rounds if you wait for another one more
gunpowder B or whatever flame rounds
aren't but magnums are way more
expensive yeah but you're not gonna be
making them you're gonna make freeze
rounds if you get the chance not the
magnums and you're gonna use freeze
rounds against nemesis can you combine
the magnums with the sea to make freeze
rounds I don't think so okay I'm not
sure alright I think that's it right the
best thing about Magnum is that you'd
fight them faster than grenades I think
right all supervisors mission terminated
returned immediately repeat all
supervisors returned immediately over
I say just do the electricity any way
you want to worry about so you're saying
don't shoot him just dodging for a while
oh I just found three more ink ribbons
and that guy's [ __ ] collar maybe it's
worth just saving now just did not do
this yeah just not listening this prick
talk to me again
yeah you've managed to stay alive up
until now I'll put them in the save room
just to see and we can make me home to
be doing a pretty good job of looking
out for yourself how about it depends on
like how how much time I have left in
this world do I play as Carlos again in
a manner of speech oh now you are our
employers without health analysis of the
zombie beings which were created through
infection by the t-virus you're saying
that they deliberately sent in a
military unit to be butchered by their
creations
not exactly although the conditions
encountered on this operation were
extreme it was an unexpected outcome
that the team would be wiped out we were
only required to collect live data from
the subjects
another mutant let's see how many pucks
we got we'll make a call I really did
not accomplish very much since my last
day
yeah you can save do all this stuff
first okay so now if you want to use the
magnum rounds though like if I'm
shooting a [ __ ] light pole light pole
I don't want to so what do you think I
should do then
like what do you maybe bring though
maybe make flame rounds and bring them
if you want I'm so confused I don't
think you know what you want anymore
No
what about the grenade launcher or sorry
the mine launcher maybe this would be
good against him I'll just do Magnum
bring the handgun though to shoot the
light pole - I'm so confused why would I
use don't bring grades don't like don't
waste them you just told me - I know I'm
changing my mind you're still bringing
so use the Magnum on a light pole no
just I'm saying bring it in case like
the light pole thing isn't time-based
like I thought just covering our bases
like I think but bring the hand guy to
shoot the light bulb see a handgun -
give me more healthier brain
bring the red and green herb - just so
we don't - in case you do get hit a lot
this is all the help they have in the
world though yeah just don't use it
so sorry just to be clear you're saying
that I shouldn't hit the worm just evade
it for long enough and that light pole
thing will happen I think it's a
time-based pretty positive and then once
it does try to go near the water but
then there's that like go near the water
get it to come out in the water
shoot the light boys that's why it
shouldn't be hard to hit that's why I
like it your eyes toward it use that
flame around on it last time on the
light pole mm-hmm
that's what top of it a handgun shotgun
whatnot
because she did get very bad words
turning up
it's hard to tell where he's gonna be I
think it's gonna keep well I don't
really know what to do about that that
wasn't smart try not to go into one he's
dead I mean okay like evade it through
here
nice place for the holidays I'm getting
a cabin with people I like and no family
I didn't it didn't work
it's not working
stupid stupid I don't I don't understand
the plan I'm gonna be honest with you
removing the light pole thing should
happen soon I'm just taking a [ __ ] ton
of damage well I was shooting him before
Hey all right now see that like patch of
land next to the water just try to get
him to come out around the water and
then shoot the light post make sure you
don't do it when he's not on the water I
don't like waste it so wait I cannot be
in the water right I mean it's not gonna
kill you it just gonna do it it did lat
so how do I get him in the water just go
next to it he'll come out he'll come
into it just like right now
noise thank you dead too early I did
piggy done too late I did it
fine just no way it'll go over the water
Rosie
there you go Who am I doing
not go in the water with no it doesn't
go I know for a fact that's supposed to
try like go next to the there's that
patch of land right next to the water
mm-hmm can you shoot that other
lighthouse
of course
oh you got hit the other light goes to
which other like oh you did nevermind
okay it should that you just got a hit
though with my post you did it that
couldn't have happened halfway through
the fight and you could have just run
how am i doing alright I'm out of health
not very good
should I check the worm or something
skating about dude I like starting to
worry that I won't be able to beat this
game yeah like you need health to get
through I'm out of health we could just
make the save you just did the one you
don't overwrite I guess yeah yeah oh
okay hey remember
I remember when dyeing once made me
upset mm-hmm I feel like I feel like I'm
really hardened up from this experience
yeah four will be a breeze I can't
believe it how hard these games are oh
these guys weren't here sorry that was
stupid no sorry sorry if I die I'm gonna
be really upset I'm sorry
and I want to talk about it by god
you're not that far from the end of the
game I feel mentally like the farthest
from anything in the world
well let's fight that worm again this is
the worst game of my life just fight the
gravedigger again now that you are you
doing I have to it seems to work well
when you shot it a couple times in
weapon I didn't save like I I have no
other option for me in the episode we
got a four minutes
okay how many minutes we have I this
could be good you could do it with using
less health
I feel like I just like need actually a
goddamn refresh of like my life I just
so broken at this point do you think it
was time-based still yeah and you don't
think I need this Magnum now you think I
had enough shotgun shells and stuff mhm
I bring handgun rounds for the zombies
later around a few probably shoot them
this time instead of we all know how
much I love dying so I give it one more
whirl you know really shake it up a
notch
I just can't survive this game all right
I like are just typically you go into a
situation saying like oh I was supposed
to do it this way and I noticed shoot
those poles but I still don't think I
understand how to shoot the worm
oh my god
yeah you just don't want to get you
could try using like the water to get
around instead of it let corner you know
I mean she's like that nice do it didn't
work like nice
okay well it's okay so shooting it does
help I think like I think it doesn't use
ammo sparingly I mean [ __ ] shoot it
oh no no yeah yeah let's go to the other
side so if you can just get it to come
up way over there then you can go past
it before it comes above ground you I
mean right what it's about
just keep running
he's at without show yourself you big
dum-dum
go
hurt I think I'm I can make one more
right I think I did take one more from
him right makes me nervous
also just when there's because he never
just shoot those two okay he's back
anything go go go [ __ ] wait for the
letterbox let me pull off the other
cutscenes gonna happen
I don't know what the justification is
what the shaking makes a lamppost loose
I hole things
didn't work okay
I would shoot it I mean the health is
sorry I think you all right I just go
shoot them and you got it don't go in
the water though obviously you got it
okay so wait should I do it with a
shotgun channel or with did the handgun
work last time
I didn't do it I know try it out [ __ ]
[ __ ] isn't she picks a sheep hey it
looks like a boy to me ah safe - huh
okay it's worth it it's worth it does
look like a guy that's like an HR Giger
design monster now don't skimp on
shotgun shells me shooting these zombies
you got it
I'm going to kill everything well not
everything use common sense just don't
get too complacent all right oh man
morale is back to neutral yeah
oh I forgot goddamn slugs everything
[ __ ] kills me in this goddamn game
nothing get up a ladder probably use Han
Han rounds to take out some of them
right
probably yeah
some going straight across I'm pretty
sure yes sorry I know I know I mean now
I had a plan it just died very fine
remember when I died there I remember
you you're getting a gun and I'm gonna
kill you do down one down see the last I
thought that was - sorry I got excited I
think you're right
he's taking this damn time I got places
to be coming back really he's dead other
rounds were a waste one of the rounds
the ones you shot him with already it's
like I think if it's like the first two
games and has helped would have reset
right I don't know that it's like the
first is it like that for the whole
series
yeah well it's from the next like Code
Veronica and zero I think so as well
oh it didn't say discard mm-hmm well at
least they're consistent
have a cold going around here in the
office
you're in a room with me oh my god is
that the goddamn nemesis no no no no no
no wish I do wish I do [ __ ] you
damn she's strong are you controlling
that I don't know I was trying to go
forward and she was also going for it so
it's hard to tell because we had the
same goal okay I'm fine I could use a
lot more weapons and I have to health so
I'm okay but I'd really like to get to a
save room based on my heart condition
come on
save room Carlos Carlos Jill listen very
carefully they're planning on launching
a missile directly into the city as soon
as day breaks the explosion will be
powerful enough to destroy everything
are you sure about that
positive I heard it straight from a
supervisor they'll go this far to cover
their tracks come on we have to hurry
there isn't much time left is this a
safe room yes
oh sweet just kill that [ __ ] around and
then save it where's the box okay good
Oh Gold yeah we had a positive episode I
needed that okay good I feel better
we're doing okay
how do you feel again checkout locker
way there's increments on the table it
looks like
[Music]
that's the thing should I go out there
no no save it I think they're increments
right there where on the table on the
table with this thing
[Music]
so much for your birthday party
[Music]
I guess if you have the keycard it's
useless when you are locked inside
interesting
[Music]
nice okay just wearing me down I I am
mentally not the same person I was from
when we started this series no this game
this game specifically is wearing on me
Oh actually I wanted to overrate the
other one that's right okay cool okay
that was not terrible sweet can ultimate
maybe this one's not the Delphic now
next
[Music]
who knows they want to leave
[Music]